sì ma stai calmo bella giunti ragazzi
prevenuti questo video sono farisei e
oggi siamo su venerdì 13 killer puzzle
dovrebbe essere tipo crystal lake
memories perfetto dovrebbe essere tipo a
step che bello chess classic supermax
jason rose in gesù quanti jason esistono
e papà mi sembra un po esagerato che
abbiamo fatto così tanti già bene
comunque
usiamo il primo è una specie di non lo
so non so spiegarlo provvediamo livello
uno di 13 e ben figurati se non
metteranno 13 livelli c'è seguire a
questa la mamma usa le frecce per
muoverti attaccato che mai sono jason
non sono il tipo che scappa ma io sono
jason kidd o mio dio
eccomi qua ok va bene quindi io devo
uccidere tutti quanti non avevan tasti
co
aica ho capito il tipo il coso di
pokémon che devi trovare la strada
giusta per ucciderlo
no la vera figata incredibile tra
l'altro fanno veramente ridere le morti
sto gioco che se poi c'e la final kg
ogni volta ho capito manara figata
quindi è una specie di l'ho mancato
non ci credo prof a rifare sul banco
anno la mancato e basta ci sono riuscito
a mancare il livello 2 pensate devi
riuscire a risolvere perché lui si può
muovere solo in una direzione ed air
affidata come cosa perché un'andata ci
ho messo una vita per farla fuori
l'altro dovrebbe essere così però non è
l'ultimo manca ancora uno
ecco lo vedevo riuscirci ore
dettagli incredibili va bene grazie
questo vuol dire ha una nuova arma
equipaggia ma poi mi piacciono gli
urletti mascolini che fanno tutti quanti
sono fantastici
quello si caga addosso ma morto ma
cambiano anche le kill è sì colpire di
levate dai fatte mio cosa stanno facendo
più sporca ciani qua dentro
se tu fai qua ok no la sedia non la
posso superare tipo in the sims porca
vacca se parte difficile eccolo
ecco che arriva per fa guarda come
goduto quello eccolo che arrivo ci siamo
beh mi stupisce ogni chilo di più
meno male che la final chille sempre
vicino non mi devo far casini per
raggiungerla
ho parlato ma i livelli più avanti se
non impossibili prove beh questo è
semplice poverina no
sarà affogato posso anche morire ok le
star del è vero che li facciamo per
quindi se muori come facebook e va via
non posso raggiungerlo quel punto
ovunque vado un bucato come faccio scusa
impossibile ok non devo ammazzare più a
ok non devo andare devo prenderla da un
altro lato perché sono muoio michele
incasina sono studiata bene visto gioco
porca vacca non l'ha neanche preso
l'occhio ai e perciò your speciali works
and you're very special thanks ma grazie
mamma va bene non cagati addosso che
devo ucciderti allora fammi capire un
attimo come facciamo
oddio massonica strato fortissimo adesso
come faccio uscire scusa aiuto sono
incastrato negli angoli mamma aiutami
non posso uscire è parte che ho fatto un
miliardo di morse quindi prima che torno
indietro
ok ok quindi anche stavolta lo devo
prendere da un lato storto perché ok
perfetto che non ha ok perfetto
no gesù quello così si puliscono i
tappeti non le persone
vabbè dettagli ma non era neanche la
kill finale pensatelo mancato ma porca
vacca quanto faccio schifo dovete per
forza mettere il maschio dietro una
femmina base scemo credo che io debba
evitare il fuoco qualcosa amici di sì
quindi va bene iniziamo sono uno più
deficiente dell'altro legale con la
musica che addosso sapevo sono dei
deficienti
let's go bere più brutta barba che hai
zio pronto mancato solo perché xavi la
barba e non la posso avere quindi cioè
per ripicca toe ucciso fammi vedere che
cosa sbloccherò pinocchio ok allora
proviamo col tronco vero ragazzi siete
veramente la avete studiato ad harvard
tutti quanti era i geni
ecco pure io non è che sto messo bene
perché sono incastrato ma porca eva ma
perché parlo e devo uscire alcune uccide
questo
[Musica]
ha così mi fa ridere quando si cagano
addosso perché non ha veramente senso va
bene fa vedere la vostra speciale con
tronco e vabbè con che fisica 13 13
siamo all'ultimo livello ragazzi ci
siamo the last one chase è la vendetta è
tua
va bene mamma dopo mi prepari la pasta
che ho fame ecco mi sa che non la mangio
la pasta nera spetta di questo motivo
più complicato madonna quanto sono
scarso porca vacca morta perché devo
passare da destra ecco infatti ok
perfetto ace la cinematica finale
attenzione non ci sono più
dove jason è sott'acqua zio severini
gameplay lo scopri dovresti saperlo che
sott'acqua in teoria la forza non ero a
ma non muoiono se vanno in acqua non
potevano notare fuori anche gli altri a
caso completamente a caso se va beh ok
beh risparmierò sul materassino per
quest'estate perfetto ea ci sono ma
torno a quanti livelli mandiamo col
prossimo ragazzi lock down e bellissimo
mi piace tantissimo ha sbloccato lo ha
ucciso supermax jason ok possiamo usare
questo quando vai
e bello jason arancione cosa ne in
galera è colpevole hanno arrestato sceso
ma cosa ma dove come fai ad arrestare
cenco la maschera tra l'altro ha dato di
andato alla sedia elettrica sta bene
ragazzi ce l'avete nel sacchetto io ve
lo dico a uno di 13 st info rappresen
breaking dawn led casta più
e ora di evadere di prigione sceso a tu
non puoi picchiare le guardie degli
evitare le guardie
va bene la guardia è alta così la potrei
far fuori sputandole addosso oppure anno
la devo prendere da davanti a ok non
avevo capito bene con gli altri
carcerati che non c'entrano niente
poverini
vabbè nonché quelli che fuggono di
solito in vena di 13 c'entrino qualcosa
seguire quello che mi dice la mamma la
teiera evadere di prigione con una
teiera noi noi possiamo farlo ragazzi ok
perfetto non avevo non avevo capito il
meccanismo lescot fammi vedere la teiera
come la usi fammi vedere zio
la cosa ma con quale fisica se starò
acquistare a turni devo farlo in un
totti rimosse
sì effettivamente bastava fare così
perfetto
[Musica]
ok questa già già già è un po più fisica
di colari prima il che dice tutto
ti ricordi such as with more questo è
uno stufato io mi do fuoco
ma che problemi al cervello
no non è vero porca vacca man inglobato
di nuovo a ok non spostarlo dall'altra
parte madonna che casino forse forse ho
sbagliato di nuovo tra l'altro non è
neanche giusto così come la e come lei
sgozzato famiglia come come live gold
accorto va beh forse non è affatto
sbagliato lo stesso pensate
no giusto perfetto questo e artù rito
quello di la casa di carta perfetto
andato a vedere il microfono cioè basta
registrare una puntata dei social face
non facciamo domande ragazzo a questo
via quello s'è intrufolato in mezzo alle
guardie però la mazza uguale le guardie
non devo ammazzarle per forza ma dove ma
dove dove lo vedi dal taglio dove agli
ami le cipolle go il microfono 13 di
tredici ragazzi l'ultimo maximum
security te l'abbiamo fatta da che
l'ultimo praticamente il direttore della
prigione va bene una guardia via casa
sarà difficile raga perché lo vedo che
veramente incastrato come livello se
cosa guardia via emo mi voglio ma un
casino porca vacca del suo casinò sul
serio allora un attimo ma devo andare a
sinistra che casino
voglio tornare tutto indietro
ok è far fuori cubo questo
credo questo me lo faccio fuori
così però non prendo più il direttore
maledizione
porca vacca sì l'ho preso l'ho preso
perfetto a ci metto lui sulla sedia
elettrica avvenne noto brutta questa
scena
cosa vedo come si incastra tale va a
cosa ok va bene ok vale raga io per oggi
va bene così concludo 4 il video vi sia
piaciuto fateci sapere se volete un
altro episodio se lo volete che continui
con gli altri livelli a me sembra carino
o poi va beh ditemi voi se vi sia
piaciuto lo stesso che conosce quanto mi
piace anche a vari social condizioni non
sapresti schede dio ci vediamo un po
stupito dai ragazzi
[Musica]